Well, judgi- oh, time.
>> Yes. So, we shouldn't be approving any bookings if there isn't
an actual time for them to be booked at. because then it's incomplete.
>> So, use this approval process if set time
is equals blank and just kind of just leave it blank?
>> Is not equal to blank. Because if.
>> All right, Sorry. Not equal to blank.
>> Yeah.
>> So this means if, if a time is
set, then we need to see an approval process.
>> Yeah. In order to set an approval
process, you have to push the Submit for
Approval button, but if they push that button and
there is no time set, it shouldn't fire this
approval process, because it's not ready to be approved.
>> Gotcha.
>> So you can leave that blank.
>> Blank.
>> Yeah.
>> Makes sense.